this is how I spell the word church
it's wrong or is it tea can make a cha
sound look at the word picture and Olo
is obviously pronounced ER kernel T
again making a Chuck gives us church now
this might remind you of that Old
Chestnut goatee but this doesn't spell
goatee oh no this is a way to spell fish
the GH makes the F sound we see in
enough the O is pronounced like the O in
women and the ti is like the ti in
nation fish now if all of this has you
thinking what why let me explain this is
not OED the Oxford English Dictionary
this is a way to spell the word what the
O is pronounced like the O in one and
the Ed is pronounced with a TA like in
hacked and this how is this why well
take a look why
why why